تدرون انه اكل لغه عالميه قادمه جديده
اللي هي لغه البرمجه
بالسبعينات العصر الذهبي
انجاز وسفر
[موسيقى]
الثمانينات جيل الطيبين
ايش قضيناها تحدي وراء تحدي وراء تحدي
اول تحدي بحياتي
كان اول حب بحياتي
اول حب حياتي
جهاز الاميبا
اللي ما كان موجود بكل بيت مثل ما هسه
احنا اغلب البيوت لو عندهم اجهزه موبايل
نوع عندهم اجهزه لابتوب
لكن من حسن حظي انه كان بيت خالتي عندهم
جهاز
انتظر العطله الصيفيه طارغ الصبر حتى
عقلنا الست الوالده اروح ببيت خالتي حتى
تدعى العبوا بهذا الجهاد
اكو وحده من الالعاب اللي بقت وياي حياتي
كلها لحد هسه
شخصيه بنيه قدها طابات ناريه قدامها وحوش
ما يخلوها تتقدم وهي شو تسوي بكل شجاعه
تشمر بحال الطوباتهم
من قدامها وتمشي
زين باقي
الرغبه انه انا اريد العب هاي اللعبه اريد
اني اكون هاي الشخصيه اريد اني اكون هاي
شجاعه
شفت انه اقوى
شيء اني امتلكه هي مخيلتي
راحت جبت اوراق
رسمت كيبورد
لي شاشه الالعاب
شكرا
فكرت شنو سويت
اخلي بهلوا عيب
تعلمت انه انا شلون اكون منظمه وشلون اسوي
بياناتي
هذا الشيء يمكن
احسن شيء صارت حياتي
انه انا عرفت شنو اللي اريد قصيره وانا
بامر عشر سنوات
انا عرفت اني احب الحاسوب
2013 انا سافرت البريطانيا اخذت شهاده
الدكتوراه من جامعه برونال لندن
[تصفيق]
وجودي بجامعه بروناون
بالذات هذا انطاني
وحده من عندها انه الجامعه
موجود
وطلاب الدراسات العليا ماجستير والدكتوره
يقدرون يتطوعهن عشان يقدرون يطلعوني
يقدرون يطلعون من فتشي ايييييه شيء اسمه
بال 2016
الجامعه شلون تعرف هذا الطالب عندما حاره
المكتب شعبه او وحده مثل وحده التاهيل
والتطوير
المؤسسات والشركات تخاطب الجامعه وتنطيها
فرص التطوع والطلاب يقدمون على هذه الفرص
بشكل امن من خلال وبابسه الوبسات للجامعه
كل سنه تصير اكم مسابقه
الطالب المتطوع يقدم ساعات التطوعيه
ويقدم تقرير بادله باثباتات لكل المهارات
اللي هو تعلمها
اعلى جائزه هي الجائزه الذهبيه
الجائزه الذهبيه هي للطالب اللي يكون عنده
100 ساعه تطوعيه او اكثر ويكون محقق على
الاقل ثمان مهارات
بال 2017
انا مو بس حصلت على الجائزه الذهبيه اني
حصلت على درع الابداع
السبب هو لعدد الساعات الكثيره الان كنت
اطوح رغم انه اني طالب الدكتور ورغم انه
اني ام
ولي نوعيه التدريبات والنوعيه التطوع اللي
انا كنت اقدي اكثر ساعات تطوعيه اني
سويتها واللي افتخر بيها هي التطوع كمدربه
لنادي برمجه
بمدرستك
عفوا لمكتبه اكرم
عايشه فيها
وجودي هنا ويا هؤلاء الاطفال
ذكرني بناديه ناديه اللي كان عندها عشر
سنوات اللي ما كان عندها حاسبه وناديه
اللي ما كان ادهم منتور يقدر يساعدها
ويقول لها او تقول لها تسوي هذه الخطوه
حقيقيه هذا الهدف روحي اقرف هذا الكتاب
روحي سوي هذا البرنامج
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
رجعت للعراق بحلم
اني اساس النوادي واجيبها لاطفال
لمدارسنا
لمكتباتنا العامه لمؤسساتنا
واكيد
اول محطه كانت في محافظه ميسان محافظه
بال 2018 احنا اسسنا اول نادي برمجه
بالعراق
كتابنا انه احنا نبدي بتدريب مدربات لانه
احنا نريد نقلل من الفجوه التقنيه للنساء
هؤلاء المدربات بداوهم يدربون الاطفال
ومن بعدها اجت في جائعات كرونه
كانت تحدي للعالم كله
اسمه علينا
اطفال وبالنسبه لنا كانت لكم
هي نقطه انطلاق ونقطه التوسع كتابنا ندرب
مئات الاطفال وعشرات المدربين من عدد من
المحافظات العراقيه مو بس هيك احنا قدرنا
ننطي تدريب لمجموعه اطفال
لعوائل لاجئه ساكنين بعمان
انا اليوم واقفه وياكم جدا سعيده وجدا
فخوره انه انا اقول لكم انه احنا ما
متواجدين فقط ميسان احنا عندنا مدربين
متطوعين يجيرون نوادي البرمجه اللي هي
اصلا هي نوادي برمجه مجانيه الهدف من
عندها انه احنا ننطي المهارات وننطي
التعلم للاطفال بلا تمييز من عمر سبع
سنوات الى عمر 17 سنه احنا هسه حاليا
متواجدين في بغداد
ديوانيه بابل والنجف عندنا تسعه
عندنا تسع نوادي يجيروها متطوعين يديروها
اشخاص مؤمنين بشيل يعني اؤمن بيه
ومحطتنا الجايه
الموصل
كربلاء والبصره
وهذا السبب انه اليوم اني جايه من محافظه
ميسان الكم يا اهل البصره نحنا حاليا
محتاجين مساعدتكم احنا محتاجين المساعده
باداره نادي تطوع بالاداره وتاسيس نادي او
على الاقل المساعده بتاسيس النادي
صدقوني من اقول لكم احلى شعور بالدنيا انه
انت تنطي معلومه
للطفل انه انت تغير مفهوم طفل انه انت
تخلي بنيه خجوله انه هي تقوم توقف تحكي
تقوم توقف تحكي قدام مئات الاشخاص ويقوم
هي تعلم الاولاد شلونهم ما يبرمجون اللي
انتم راح تسووا تقدر معكم
نفس الوقت تحصلون مهارات كثيره جدا تفيدكم
انتم بسوق العمل
اني بديت بحلب
بس
اني ما وصلته هنا بسهوله انا في كل خطوه
عالي اخطيها انت مجموعه من التحديات يمكن
خمس دقائق ثم راح تكفي
لكن دائما انا احب الايجابيه وايضا انه
اقول لكم انه احنا يعني اليوم ما قدرت
اوقف هناك وما قدرنا نحقق كل هذه
الانجازات وما قدرنا نكون الشركه الرسمي
انا عندي فريق رائع
انا عندي فريق رائع ده يشتغلون الليل نهار
حتى يمنحون اولادكم وبناتكم فرصه التعلم
في ذلك انا شاكر اليوم الهم
رسالتي
انا عندي رساله بسيطه
شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]